for more on the busy 24 hours in
Washington we turn to ed O'Keefe a
congressional reporter for the
Washington Post and a CBS News
contributor ed good morning good morning
guys
how did Republicans get to the finish
line in the early hours of this morning
ed
yeah 149 am anthony most things don't
happen in this town that late or early
in the morning look they had to cut some
deals with various Republicans to make
sure that they would vote for this thing
when you only have 52 Republicans in the
Senate and who needed at least 50 there
was some horse trading to be done among
other things they made some changes to
how much you can deduct in your property
taxes how much certain so-called
pass-through companies will be able to
benefit from tax cuts and even had to do
things like permit drilling in the
Alaska National Wildlife Refuge in order
to get votes from Lisa Murkowski the
senator from Alaska so a lot of horse
trading this is how legislating works
and Republicans did what they needed to
do at the speed with which this was done
is fairly unprecedented Democrats were
not happy about their ability to review
the bill senator Claire McCaskill said
that she got revisions from lobbyists
rather than her own colleagues across
the aisle did Republicans know what was
in this bill I think it's fair to say
Alex that no member of the US Senate
read the whole thing or and is totally
aware of what's in it Mitch McConnell
makes a good point when you're
complaining about process you're losing
but Democrats have a fair point as well
you have more than 500 roughly 500 pages
of new tax policy that adds more than
1.5 trillion dollars to the deficit most
likely and how can you be passing that
without you know taking a breath and
trying to sort out what exactly is in
there similar charges were made back in
the day when the Affordable Care Act was
passed and Republicans complained that
Democrats are Russia in the process but
you know as McConnell said when you're
losing this is all you can really
complain about and remember this is not
the final product the house and the
Senate now have to get together over the
next few days try to come up with a
final compromise undoubtedly you're
going to see similar rush jobs on
certain aspects of the legislation but
this is not the final product that is
you alluded to that the Senate bill gets
rid of most state and local tax
deductions which is gonna hurt tax
in states like New York New Jersey
California and big cities that have high
local taxes is this a potential problem
with with Republican House members in
those states it is they did not vote for
the house plan because there were
essentially no deductions for folks from
those states they call it salts state
and local taxes and so we've been
calling the lawmakers concerned about
this saltines for the last several weeks
and and they're gonna be a factor in the
final negotiations because there's about
20 of them in the house and Republicans
can't afford to lose too many votes the
compromise in the Senate was that folks
could deduct up to ten thousand dollars
in your property taxes we'll see if
that's an acceptable compromise to those
Republicans in the house and there is a
government shutdown looming is there not
ed that's right
Friday circle your calendars if Congress
can't pass some kind of short-term
spending plan by then we may have a
partial government shutdown as if there
wasn't another enough drama in
Washington already ed O'Keefe thank you
very much